哈喽 我这下的零我发现画装这种喜态
真的不是说粉约后就约好
给你们看一下我跟着网上的教程
然后折出来的那个想
这脸上的粉约后又看
然后给你们看一下
我偷许你个画装吃的手法
然后你折出来的想
就是很轻薄
但是该折的你帮用折主了
今天的这个视频
我建议跟我一样有片圈园呀
或是有斗硬有斗斗
有斗筋姐妹都收藏起来
你们画装的时候一定会用的导
而且我分享的方法非常简单
是新手啊
想摆都可以许的会
那我先说眼下的这个折下
那很多人就解这个眼下折下的
到底是在谁之前上来是在粉约之后上
就观察很多画装是他们其实在上粉底的前后
和粉约的一点
第一边呢
一般是先叫色
用这种约粉
或者是这种偏举的折下
先来调和一下
我们眼下那种泛清啊
或者是泛滴的黑眼圈
然后会用到这种刷头很薄的水彩底
来当这下刷
这个其实是美书是用来花的刷
它的这个刷头
能和我们这个眼下完美的融合当期
然后举粉呢
也是很细节很讲究的
如果我们用这个刷子直接沾了这个高体
然后直接上面的花能
这个粉絕是取得太后的
就会让我们的眼下看起来又看又后
所以正确的用法呢
应该是先沾了它之后呢
在这种调色盘
或者是在那个镜子上
把它给冰开
冰到什么程度呢
冰到它像这种不一样
非常薄的时候
就可以把它商量
这个时候的量就是切到好处的
然后我们就给直接沾一下
把它给冰开
给你们看
这两边的区别
这个是我刚刚用过的
这不是战略
它很薄很薄
而且很好的终魄掉了
我们整个黑眼军的眼色
那怕是我反复得去这么点架
它也完全不会厚足
之外之后我们就可以直接上粉底了
但是要注意到就是眼下
我们刚才直过下的这一块
即将不要用海脸淡去冰到它
上了粉底之后
然后再拿出这个折霞盘
捐一个跟我们粉底的色号
非常接近的颜色
也可以用这种
三色的这样盘子
调出一个比较适合你膚色的颜色
然后就是用同样的手法
给我们的这个眼下
再折一次
这边我们基本上
就把黑眼圈的机器发发了
我会把握残的
这一份保留出来
因为我觉得
握残
如果也只会到下来的话
会到我们的眼睛显得很小
最后呢
一定要做的就是眼下的
定装
然后取定让粉腦
就是我们先强了粉
然后再我们的手上
先拍一下
多余的粉拍掉眼睛向上看
让眼下的
这种纹路都撑开
然后捏住粉铺
用这种透明的三粉
轻轻的
按摇在我们的眼中
这样这个眼下折霞
这一天都没折得很短
而且这个折眼下手法
你也可以用它来折一些
我们的红色和赫色的这种动硬
出来了下文
要是非常轻薄的
而且因为我们用量很少
它就不会让我们的底装写的
好种
然后我们游动其实还不经常
长一些出奇的动动
那种我们就是要用到这种
小的红色双来折霞
折霞的用量
要比我们在眼下用的
身位多一些
大概是这个用量
占取之后直接往豆豆的
这位只能垂直的
出我干上去
这个时候你就不要那种
来回的滑了
就是这样垂直
出我怕的这个
负责力才会强
才会折住我们的那种
通常动动同色的
只能粉底液
再往上给它
感以轻轻的用这个美装蛋
把这个豆豆周围的粉底给它理它
但是注意
这个豆豆上面的这面
刺就不要给它站倒
然后再用那一份
上位的给它定中
如果在折霞这种历体的红色
豆豆的时候呢
我们要输立完就要好的其他
因为它本身它就是一个历体的
我们没有办法去完全把这个
历体跟成平面
在不同的光影下
看了它多多少少还是呢
看出来一次的
所以这种红色
到如果能折霞
其实已经很不错了
完全就是日常的
摄像情况
你看看是
OK的可以接受